bien mes chers collègues madame la
Présidente
nous sommes évidemment heureux de vous
accueillir aujourd'hui pour évoquer le
rôle des experts-comptables et défis
auxquels ils sont confrontés je rappelle
que vous avez été élu président du
Conseil national de l'Ordre en décembre
dernier et que vous représentez
désormais environ 21000 professionnels
qui sont les premiers interlocuteurs des
chefs d'entreprise en particulier les
patrons de TPE et PME ce que nous
évoquions en aparté c'est donc une
immense responsabilité dans un contexte
de fort bouleversement pour les
entreprises avec de nouvelles
obligations notamment en matière de RSE
mais également de défi tels que la
facturation électronique effectivement
un autre sujet de partage de la valeur
ou la transition écologique
nous aimerions savoir comment vous
appréhender ces questions au sein de
l'ordre que vous représentez je précise
que vous êtes accompagné de Monsieur
Hervé Bégot vice-président Charles de la
durabilité qu'il faudra compléter vos
propos dans le temps imparti en
précisant comme vous envisagez le rôle
des experts comptables dans le
traitement des données extra-financières
les experts comptables jouent un rôle
essentiel pour guider les chefs
d'entreprise la formation continue
semble donc être un défi comme nous
l'avions vu à l'occasion du récent en
rapport de la délégation sur la
transmission d'entreprise au sujet
en effet il est indispensable de
maîtriser les dispositifs législatifs en
particulier fiscaux pouvant aider les
dirigeants or ces dispositifs peuvent
évoluer au gré des lois de finance comme
ce fut le cas 2018 pour le pacte du
Treil crois savoir que la formation
constitue l'une de vos priorités aussi
pourrait vous nous dire comment vous
allez mettre en oeuvre des actions
concrètes dans ce domaine je rappelle
que depuis désormais plus de 8 ans la
délégation d'entreprises a pour mission
de recenser les obstacles au
développement des entreprises et de
proposer des mesures visant à simplifier
les normes applicables à l'activité
économique en vue d'encourager la
croissance et l'emploi dans les
territoires
le dialogue avec les chefs d'entreprise
lors de visite de terrain constitue son
ADN la semaine prochaine nous allons
fonder particulier on sort plusieurs
fois par trimestre pour aller sur le
terrain rencontrer les chefs
d'entreprise
notre délégation a déjà rencontrée
environ 2000 dirigeants au cours de la
quarantaine de déplacements effectués
dans différents départements au cours
des éditions de la journée des
entreprises organisées chaque année au
Sénat
TPE PME ti sont au cœur de
préoccupations c'est pourquoi nous
sommes particulièrement heureux de vous
entendre ce matin j'essaierai tout
d'abord la parole pour un propos
liminaire d'une durée totale de 10 à 15
minutes puis mes collègues pourront vous
poser des questions
vous préférez bien veiller à utiliser
vos micros les uns les autres qui sont
nécessaires à la bonne captation et à la
retranscription de nos échanges
je vous remercie et vous laisse madame
la Présidente la parole
mesdames
messieurs les sénateurs mesdames et
messieurs je suis honorée de pouvoir
m'exprimer devant vous aujourd'hui et
vous remercie au nom des 21 000
experts-comptables que je représente de
l'opportunité que vous nous offrez
accompagner d'Hervé degault
vice-président du Conseil national de
l'Ordre des Experts-Comptables j'ai donc
prévu d'aborder différents sujets
relatifs à la vie des entreprises
mouvementée depuis plusieurs années
mon propos ne sera pas corporatiste mais
embrassera bien le périmètre de votre
délégation à savoir les 3 millions
d'entreprises qui font le tissu
économique français et qui pour la
plupart sont accompagnés par un
expert-comptable
notre pays connaît depuis 2020 des
crises successives qu'elles soient
sanitaire énergétique en raison du
contexte international ou encore
économique avec une inflation que
certains qualifient de galopante
certains entrepreneurs alertent
d'ailleurs sur leur impossibilité à
poursuivre leur activité faute de
pouvoir assumer les charges qui en
découlent c'est le cas par exemple des
boulangers pâtissiers qui pour
lesquelles la facture énergétique
reprend des Antunes par importante du
chiffre d'affaires face à cette
situation le gouvernement s'est mobilisé
pour soutenir le pouvoir d'achat et
contenir la hausse des prix plusieurs
leviers ont été mobilisés boucliers
tarifaires et le mécanisme d'amortisseur
électricité notamment
le problème est que ces aides ont
souvent pu être complexes à mettre en
œuvre ou concerne peu d'entreprises du
fait des conditions d'éligibilité
parfois trop strictes c'est la raison
pour laquelle nous avons eu l'occasion
d'alerter et ce immédiatement notre
ministère de tutelle et avons proposé
des amendements à ces dispositifs pour
que plus d'entreprises puissent en
bénéficier et c'est de manière plus
simplifiée
j'ai dit ne pas vouloir faire ici de
corporatisme mais je dois bien avouer
que mes consœurs et confrères
expert-comptable sont aujourd'hui des
simplificateurs de complexité
administrative et que sans nous nombre
d'entreprises seraient en difficulté
pour des raisons autres qui économiques
mais si vous le voulez bien j'y
reviendrai plus tard lorsque nous allons
aborder cette danse intervention la
simplification des normes
pour revenir sur les défaillances et les
difficultés de depuis 2020 les
entreprises françaises ont montré une
forte résilience bien sûr avec le
soutien sans faille de l'État et les
aides déployées dans le quoi qu'il en
coûte mais je tiens à souligner que
c'est aussi grâce à une volonté de la
part des chefs d'entreprise de s'en
sortir
je ne peux pas dire qu'il n'y a pas eu
de casse mais globalement le mur de la
dette annoncé et les nombreuses
défaillances d'entreprises prédites ne
sont pas au rendez-vous les chiffres
parlent d'eux-mêmes certes la France a
connu la plus forte hausse de
défaillance en 2022 avec
42500k soit plus de 50% par rapport à
2021 mais moins 18,5 par rapport à 2019
période avant covid
143500 emplois ont été menacés soit
50000 de plus qu'en 2021 mais 40 000 de
moins qu'en 2019
pour les visionnaires 2023 pourra
enregistrer des chiffres proches voir
légèrement supérieure à ceux de 2019
nous sommes donc bien loin de ce que
certains pessimistes appelleraient une
défaillance généralisée
en outre permettez-moi de reprendre la
casquette d'expert-comptable un cours
instant de ramener le sol de brut des
défaillances au sol de brutes des
naissances d'entreprise afin d'obtenir
un soldes représentatif au niveau
macroéconomique de la vitalité du tissu
économique le nombre de créations a
atteint un niveau record en 2022 avec
plus d'un million d'entreprises créées
il est à noter que ce chiffre comprend
évidemment les auto-entrepreneurs c'est
donc un nombre croissant de création
qu'en registre à la France affichant
ainsi un soldes positif
pour rester dans ce positivisme encore
quelques chiffres illustrant le
dynamisme économique français
issu de notre baromètre image PME
analysant les chiffres d'affaires des
TPE sur la base des déclarations de TVA
que les experts-comptables réalisent
pour leur compte en 2022 le chiffre
d'affaires des TPE française a augmenté
de 9,5% par rapport à 2021 de 12,6 par
rapport à 2019 ce qui équivaut un taux
de croissance annuel moyen de 4%
ce résultat moyen masque toutefois des
disparités en termes géographiques et
sectorielle et est à corriger bien sûr
de l'inflation plus 8,7 depuis décembre
2019 en tout état de cause il est
difficile de parler de récession mais
soyons aussi réalistes car ces chiffres
ne peuvent pas éluder les difficultés
rencontrées par les entreprises qu'elles
soient derrière nous avec la crise covid
ou actuelle avec la crise énergétique et
le contexte inflationniste dans lequel
elles évoluent
autre sujet d'actualité pour les TPE la
digitalisation dans un monde toujours
plus connecté avec un nombre colossal de
partage de données partagées avec une
volonté de dématérialiser un maximum de
nos documents et avec toujours plus
d'échanges à distance les entreprises
doivent faire face à de nouveaux défis
émergents en premier lieu les
cyberattaques qui voient leur fréquence
exploser ces derniers mois encore
quelques chiffres pour illustrer mon
propos 60% des victimes des
cyberattaques sont des TPE PME une
entreprise sur deux déclare avoir été
victime d'une cyberattaque et en avoir
subi les conséquences ces statistiques
prennent en compte les attaques
signalées cela signifie que le non réel
de cyberattaque en France est beaucoup
plus élevé les conséquences de ces
attaques sont cruciales pour les
entreprises perte de données
indisponibilité du système informatique
arrêt de la production perte de chiffre
d'affaires et j'en passe
malheureusement les TPE PME ne sont pas
sensibilisés à ces enjeux face au risque
nous n'avons pas attendu et la
profession est aujourd'hui équipée pour
accompagner ses clients sur ce sujet
analyser leur sécurité numérique et les
aider à sequrer à se créer une identité
numérique
partenaire de confiance numéro 1 et au
cœur du fonctionnement global des
entreprises l'expert comptable possède
de nombreux atouts pour assumer son rôle
connaissance des procédures et des
systèmes prévention maîtrise des risques
si les cyberattaques sont de véritables
menaces liées à la digitalisation il
existe aussi de véritables opportunités
dans ce domaine notamment avec la
facturation électronique dès le premier
juillet 2024 l'ensemble des entreprises
seront concernées cette réforme
s’inscrit dans l'évolution mondiale de
la transmission de données tout en
voulant simplifier l'environnement
fiscal et lutter contre la fraude
les avantages de ce changement sont
nombreux gain de temps sur le traitement
des factures diminution des erreurs
suivies en temps réel et encore une
meilleure traçabilité
63% des experts-comptables que nous
avons interrogé récemment voient la
facture électronique comme une
opportunité
même si c'est encourageant du côté de
notre profession il est important de
signaler que 74% des directeurs
administratifs et financiers et
dirigeants des petites entreprises
confondent factures PDF envoyées par
mail avec factures électronique et seul
une entreprise sur trois aurait commencé
une démarche de mise en place de la
facture électronique ces shift
témoignent qu'avec l'arrivée de cette
réglementation les TPE PME françaises ne
sont pas encore prêtes
opérationnellement mais vous pouvez
compter sur les experts-comptables comme
ça a été le cas pour la mise en place de
la déclaration sociale nominative et le
prélèvement à la source pour qu'elle
soit au rendez-vous car les 3 millions
d'entreprises vont naturellement
solliciter leur premier conseiller pour
se mettre en conformité avec cette
nouvelle réglementation
qui dit facturent électronique dit moins
de papier cela me permet de faire le
lien avec un autre sujet plus que majeur
pour la profession qui est la durabilité
depuis de nombreuses années déjà la
durabilité est une préoccupation majeure
pour les entreprises et les
organisations de toute taille la prise
de conscience généralisée des enjeux
climatiques et environnementaux ainsi
que des inégalités sociales poussent les
acteurs économiques à repenser leur
stratégie et leur modèle d'affaires dans
ce contexte notre rôle à nous
expert-comptables et primordial nous
sommes garants de leur transition vers
un nouveau modèle plus durable ensemble
nous avons un devoir d'accompagnement
des entreprises vers une démarche d'une
démarche de durabilité que ce soit par
l'identification d'une aide la
décarbonation de leur activité
l'économie d'énergie l'amélioration de
leur chaîne d'approvisionnement
l'optimisation de la gestion de leurs
déchets l'aide au respect de la
réglementation sociale en matière
d'égalité et d'inclusion ou encore par
le renforcement de la formation RSE des
membres des conseils d'administration et
de direction
il est de même pour la future mise en
place de la directive européenne de
reportir extra-financier qui permettra
de mesurer et de communiquer sur les
performances environnementales sociales
et de gouvernance des organisations nous
serons ainsi en mesure de vérifier la
fiabilité des informations
extra-financières et de les intégrer
dans les containers
je laisse la parole à Hervé Bégot qui
porte ce vaste sujet depuis de
nombreuses années et qui a la charge du
nouveau secteur durabilité que j'ai
instauré sous ma présidence au sein de
l'ordre et qui siège également au comité
de l'Autorité des normes comptables qui
portent ce sujet
merci Cécile madame la sénatrice
monsieur la sénateur mesdames et
messieurs
afin de garantir un monde plus durable
deux axes de travail se dessine
premièrement
nous souhaitons faire un état des lieux
des entreprises grâce à des indicateurs
mesurés pour réduire ensuite nous avons
l'ambition de développer un outil semi
automatisé grâce à des données
provenantes des fichiers des écritures
comptables et de la donner des données
sociales nominatives ainsi que des
données manuelles
au centre des flux des entreprises notre
place nous permet d'être légitime sur la
création d'un rapport simple et
compréhensible par tous basé sur des
données faciles d'accès effectivement
salariale formation ancienneté accident
de travail consommation énergétique
consommation d'eau etc
une fois l'état des lieux dressés les
chefs d'entreprise pourront bénéficier
d'une comparabilité sectorielle
reprenons l'exemple du boulanger est-ce
que sa consommation d'énergie est si
élevée en comparaison de ses concurrents
est-ce que son four est trop
consommateur d'électricité
l'outil permettra aux entreprises de se
poser les bonnes questions pour réduire
leurs empreintes accompagner par des
incitations pour passer à l'action
ce rapport est un premier pas pour
avancer vers la réglementation
européenne émergents le fameux rapport
de durabilité la CSRD
obligatoire pour les entreprises de plus
de 250 salariés dès 2025 au titre de
l'exercice 2024 la CSRD volontaire est
aussi en construction par des groupes de
travail dont nous faisons partie au sein
de l'ephrague
de plus je copréside un groupe de
travail dans le cadre du cercle de
Giverny sur la mesure d'impact et plus
spécifiquement sur comment tirer parti
de la CSRD pour sa stratégie
d'entreprise
au cœur des discussions nous défendons
les intérêts des TPE PME présent dans la
chaîne de valeur en tant que fournisseur
des donneurs d'ordre
ces dernières par effet de ruissellement
devront structurer et rapporter leurs
impacts c'est notre devoir autant
citoyen que professionnel d'accompagner
nos clients à faire face à cette
nouvelle réglementation dans cet esprit
citoyen le Conseil national de l'Ordre
des Experts-Comptables a été auditionné
dans le cadre du projet de loi industrie
verteignant pour objectif de faire de la
France championne de l'industrie et des
technologies vertes
d'accompagner la décarbonation de
l'économie qui représente aujourd'hui
19% des émissions de gaz à effet de
serre en France
à ce titre nous avons formulé plusieurs
propositions et avons rédigé des
amendements nous sommes je suis à de
votre disposition pour le vous les
présenter le cas échéant merci dans la
présidence merci Hervé après la RSE je
souhaite évoquer devant vous le manque
de ressources dans la profession
d'expertise comptable d'ici à 2025 près
de 30 000 postes seraient à pourvoir
dans les métiers de l'expertise
comptable les cabinets peinent à trouver
de nouvelles recrues à cause d'une
attractivité fragile la profession
comptable souffre en effet tristement
d'une mauvaise image injustifiée au
regard de la richesse des missions et de
l'utilité qui est la nôtre
je suis convaincue que le changement
d'image passe par la communication mais
aussi et surtout par la formation pierre
angulaire de notre profession il nous
faut relever le défi de l'adaptation des
compétences car la numérisation est là
l'automatisation des processus de nos
cabinets doit nécessairement faire
évoluer nos pratiques en tant
qu'expert-comptable mais aussi celle de
nos collaborateurs actuels et futurs
nous avons besoin de nouveaux talents et
la formation qu'elle soit initiale ou
continue doit s'adapter pour les faire
émerger les cursus au sein des écoles
doivent être adaptées et innovants pour
orienter les diplômes du DCG et du DSCG
vers la profession comptable de demain
en abordant les enjeux de la data et de
la RSE
dans votre rapport d'information de fin
d'année intitulé faire de la RSE une
ambition et un atout pour chaque
entreprise vous préconisez d'instaurer
dans les établissements d'enseignement
supérieur et plus généralement les
formations professionnelles des modules
obligatoires de formation aux enjeux de
la RSE et de labelliser ces
établissements sensible au sujet sachez
que j'ai déjà engagé des actions en ce
sens en demandant à ce que cette
thématique au même titre que celle de la
cybersécurité soit intégrée dans le
stage d'expertise comptable et en
s'assurant que les écoles labellisées et
collent de la profession s'inscrivent
dans cette démarche
enfin pour terminer cette intervention
je souhaiterais évoquer la
simplification des normes va se sujet
s'il en est comme je vous l'ai dit tout
à l'heure les experts comptables sont
souvent assimilés à des simplifications
de complexité administrative à titre
illustratif j'ai évoqué précédemment les
aides énergies mais je peux y ajouter le
guichet unique qui aujourd'hui se résume
à simplifier la vie de l'administration
mais pas celle des utilisateurs que ce
soit les experts-comptables les notaires
les avocats et les entrepreneurs
eux-mêmes les déconvenus de ce nouveau
portail depuis le début de l'année son
nombreuses et peuvent avoir des
conséquences pour l'économie en effet
comment lever l'impôt auprès de société
nouvellement créée mais pas encore
enregistré question purement rhétorique
qui nous invite à réfléchir sur les
effets collatéraux et désastreux d'un
système défaillant
alors oui pour la simplification mais de
manière organisée tester et opérationnel
de manière moins conjoncturelle je me
dois d'aborder la complexification
grandissante des règles fiscales et
sociales qui incombe aux entreprises si
j'étais purement corporatiste je ne m'en
plaindrai pas mais nous œuvrons dans
l'intérêt des entreprises dans
l'objectif est d'assurer leur activité
et nous expert-comptables de les
accompagner de manière prospective je ne
pourrais pas être complète sur le sujet
de la simplification des normes sans
parler de la future transposition de la
directive CSRD dont Hervé vous a parlé
véritable enjeu citoyen cette future
réglementation comme vous comme vous
l'avez préconisé en fin d'année dans
votre rapport que j'ai précédemment
évoqué devrait retenir un principe de
proportionnalité du contenu des
informations extra-financières requises
en fonction de la taille et des moyens
de l'entreprise concernée
enfin nous partageons votre proposition
d'appliquer progressivement les nouveaux
référentiels RSE dans les ETI et les PME
après avoir réalisé un test
d'opérationnalités par un tiers
indépendant que pourrait être
l'expert-comptable
pour conclure cette longue intervention
vous l'aurez compris que les
experts-comptables et la délégation que
vous composez travaillent dans le même
sens des entreprises saines qui peuvent
sereinement exercer leur activité dans
un environnement administratif le plus
simple possible je vous remercie de
votre écoute et reste avec les personnes
qui m'accompagnent à votre disposition
pour toute question
merci madame la Présidente Monsieur
vice-président
vous venez de le dire on travaille dans
le même sens et tous les sujets que vous
avez évoqués ont fait l'objet de
d'études approfondie et chacun des
sénateurs ici travaillent sur l'un ou
l'autre des sujets donc je suis certain
qu'il y aura des questions
le problème ça va être de savoir dans
quel ordre et surtout de les maîtriser
dans la durée alors on commence les
questions qui veut commencer
Florence peut-être allez
[Musique]
vous vous présentez puis on l'a pas fait
merci président merci beaucoup pour pour
cette présentation oui beaucoup de
questions mais j'en laisserai un peu à
mes collègues
tout d'abord une question assez
technique sur la sur la facture
électronique en effet ça arrive très
vite est-ce que quelle est la part je me
rends pas compte de des entreprises qui
sont équipées de PGI puisque vous
évoquez que certains sont encore assez
loin de de voilà de d'avoir
entamé la démarche
et donc une autre question sur la RSE
j'avais rencontré
les experts-comptables lors de votre
congrès régional et il m'avait indiqué
que
concernant les TPE vous alliez avoir un
petit un petit recueil de bonnes
pratiques avec une dizaine de poids donc
est-ce que c'est le sujet que vous avez
évoqué tout à l'heure avec ce fichier
semi automatisé s'adresse-t-il à toutes
les entreprises y a-t-il une spécificité
pour pour les TPE
et enfin une une question sur
l'évolution du métier on a lu récemment
plusieurs articles disaient qu'avec la
digitalisation vos métiers allaient
fortement se transformer donc finalement
vous avez évoqué le DCG et le descg mais
qu'en est-il des formations j'ai envie
de dire à mon formation Bac Pro
formation BTS faut-il
comment faut-il appréhender avec cette
évolution ces formations doivent-elles
être rénovées en quel sens et qu'elle
passerait le finalement avec voilà le
DCG merci
question de méthode peut-être
on va poser toutes les questions puis
vous pourrez comme
démarrage du débat Martine Berthet
Yves on aurait pu faire dans l'ordre
mais effectivement merci président merci
pendant que j'ai encore la possibilité
de poser des questions mais je pense que
nous avons tous beaucoup de questions à
vous poser merci beaucoup pour les
éléments que vous nous avez donné
jusqu'à présent alors RSE et formation
bon je vois que c'est un sujet à la fois
le et la formation de sujets sur un pour
lequel j'ai travaillé en fin d'année et
un sur lequel je suis avec ma collègue
et Michel Canevet Cora porteur
actuellement vous êtes voilà vous êtes
bien en parler du sujet et c'est très
bien donc moi j'ai plusieurs questions
un par rapport au guichet unique qui a
été un problème en ce début d'année
est-ce que vous pouvez nous faire un
petit point vous de vos de vos retours
il semble que voilà ça aille un petit
peu mieux mais pas vraiment encore
deux j'étais hier avec le président du
syndicat des indépendants
qui me parlait de deux problèmes
et surtout des défaillances alors vous
le disiez de façon générale les
défaillances ne sont pas supérieures
pour 2022 à ce qu'elles étaient en 2019
par contre pour 2023 bon nombre semble
être en augmentation mais surtout il me
disait qu'en fait au-delà de ces
défaillances il y a beaucoup
d'entreprises de commerçants surtout qui
ferment avant d'être mis en situation de
liquidation il me parlait de 41.000
entre 41 000 entreprises en 2022 donc
deux personnes qui se disent ne plus
avoir de solutions et qui préfèrent
arrêter avant d'être en liquidation donc
est-ce que vous pouvez nous en parler ce
que vous retours sont les mêmes
et puis également un autre point pour
ces indépendants et les PGE à rembourser
ils aimeraient qu'il y ait alors pas
deux ans de report pour commencer le
remboursement mais un étalement plus
long de ce remboursement de de deux ans
de plus là aussi pouvez-vous nous en
parler et enfin mon dernier point
l'industrie verte j'étais un peu en
retard parce que j'étais avec les
industriels pour parler de ce projet de
loi là à l'instant justement pouvez-vous
nous dire quels sont les propositions
que vous faites sur ce projet de loi que
l'on n'a pas encore mais presque voilà
merci
ça va faire beaucoup de questions au
bout d'un moment
j'écoutais toutes vos démonstration sur
le partage des données sur la
facturation électronique etc etc et
j'avoue que ça me donne un peu le
tournis tout ça
parce que on a le sentiment que demain
tout va se faire
de façon électronique de façon
automatique avec un rapport tout de
suite au niveau de l'administration
fiscale qui va pouvoir exploiter les
données
deux questions quelle est la part de
est-ce que on tient bien compte de la
part de créativité des entreprises dans
ce nouveau système est-ce qu'on tient
compte de la passion de l'entrepreneur
est-ce qu'on forme à l'espace toutes les
données pour que toutes les entreprises
rentrent dans un cadre et n'en dépasse
pas
et la deuxième question c'est est-ce que
votre profession ne va pas faire les
frais de cette modernisation
dans les premiers dans les premiers les
premières victimes
deuxième troisième question revient par
rapport au PGE alors je suis un peu
comme Martine on a fait des PGO
remboursables sur cinq ans qui
représentait 25% du chiffre d'affaires
donc ça fait 5 % sur
il faut 5 % de rentabilité pour pouvoir
rembourser de CPGE
quand on n'a pas bénéficié des reports
comment les entreprises parce que la
moyenne des entreprises est plutôt
autour de un demi pour cent de
rentabilité comment les entreprises
ont-elles ouvertes cette différence
est-ce qu'elles ont
rétrogradé si on investissement pour
donc est-ce que elles ne prennent pas de
retard par rapport au futur par rapport
aux années prochaines
vice-président que la parole on abordera
peut-être
oui j'ai essayé de noter toutes vos
questions si jamais je réponds pas à
tout n'hésitez pas
le nombre d'entreprises équipées de PGI
est-ce que c'est la majorité alors je
tiens à préciser je suis pas spécialiste
de tous les domaines mais bon je vais
essayer de vous répondre
je pense qu'aujourd'hui enfin est-ce que
toutes les entreprises et notamment les
TPE ont un PGI je vais dire que la
majorité en ont parce que la majorité
des TPE PME travail avec des
experts-comptables et que on les pousse
à
s'informatiser est-ce qu'ils ont tous
compris la facture électronique ça c'est
un autre débat puisque je voulais dire
dans mon propos il confondent souvent
facture envoyer facture PDF envoyée par
mail et facture électronique mais ça ça
va être de notre mission de les
accompagner
là-dedans dans cette transformation
d'autant plus que en forme de façon
assez massive depuis
quelques années les experts-comptables
pour cet accompagnement donc voilà et
puis on se rapproche de l'échéance bien
sûr plus la formation vient intensive
la digitalisation reliée à la formation
initiale et aux diplôme alors j'ai parlé
effectivement du DCG du DCG parce que
globalement je suis expert-comptable et
c'est la voie royale pour arriver on va
dire Royal entre guillemets pour arriver
à l'expertise comptable souvent on passe
par cette formation là mais il y a
différentes filières pour arriver à
l'expertise comptable il y en a d'autres
on aimerait on aimerait que toutes ces
nouvelles contraintes enfin ou
opportunité soit mise
dans l'enseignement aussi bien au niveau
du baccalauréat aussi bien au niveau des
BTS etc
on pousse là dessus on a donc un secteur
formation qui s'occupe la formation
continue la formation initiale on a pris
en main on va dire entre guillemets sur
la région parisienne une école qui
s'appelle fond la montée une école qui
s'appelle sup expertise qui est un
centre d'apprentissage et qui dépend du
conseil de régional de l'ordre des
experts-comptables où on essaye de
mettre des modules innovants justement
pour tenir compte de la digitalisation
et des compétences parce qu'on est
parfaitement conscient que les
compétences dont on va avoir besoin
demain ce sont pas celles d'aujourd'hui
dans les cabinets d'expertise comptable
donc on essaye on essaye de de d'être
force de proposition
mais c'est le ministère de
l'enseignement supérieur ou l'éducation
nationale donc ça dépend puisque notre
diplôme est un diplôme d'état et voilà
on fait des propositions régulièrement
et on va continuer à faire des
propositions pour faire évoluer le
cursus de formation le seul parti sur
laquelle on a vraiment une action c'est
le stage d'expertise comptable ou là par
contre on peut être très influent après
le reste c'est le ministère de
l'enseignement supérieur mais bon on
essaye
oui
je sais pas si c'est politiquement
correct de le dire mais oui c'est
difficile c'est difficile c'est très
difficile
pour compléter ma question est-ce que
cette digitalisation change la structure
des emplois niveau Bac niveau bac +2
niveau bac +3 et plus voilà c'est un
petit peu ça va ça va forcément avoir un
impact forcément maintenant est-ce que
ça va être un impact comme ça le premier
juillet 2024 facture électronique tout
non mais ça va se faire dans la durée et
ça va se faire je veux dire
naturellement parce que on va comme je
vous l'ai dit dans mon dans mon propos
préliminaire c'est les compétences des
futurs collaborateurs mais aussi des
actuels parce que c'est de notre
responsabilité à nous expert-comptable
employeur de préserver l'employabilité
de nos collaborateurs et donc ça passera
par la formation continue ou là on
maîtrise complètement le sujet et après
ça découlera sur la formation initiale
et sur les nouvelles compétences dont on
aura besoin de toute façon l'éducation
nationale sera bien obligée de se mettre
en phase avec les besoins du marché
je vois pas comment on peut être
déconnecté complètement donc voilà donc
je pense que ça enfin je suis pas
inquiète alors ça se fait pas aussi vite
qu'on le souhaiterait ça c'est sûr mais
ça se fera
guichet unique point état des lieux
alors là
guichet unique alors ça c'est la c'est
la c'est la grosse surprise du début de
l'année alors état des lieux la création
on va y aller par étape parce qu'on a la
création les modifications là cessation
et je vous parlerai aussi du dépôt des
comptes donc j'ai évoqué avec monsieur
le Président les difficultés à venir les
créations ça fonctionne à peu près bien
on a beaucoup moins de difficultés
aujourd'hui sur les créations ça ça peut
fonctionner modification cessation c'est
toujours compliqué
très compliqué
et alors le dépôt des comptes comment
vous dire les greffes aujourd'hui
refusent 95% c'est ça je me trompe
j'allais dire 99 mais j'exagère 95% des
dépôts des comptes sont refusés par les
greffes aujourd'hui sachant que le plus
haut de la période de dépôt des comptes
ça va être juin juillet puisque la
majorité des entreprises dans notre pays
clôture pour exercice au 31 décembre si
on n'est pas en mesure de déposer les
comptes annuels sur la période de juin
juillet on risque d'avoir à l'automne
des ruptures de crédit pour les
entreprises et bien sûr les plus
impactés ça va être les tpeme on est
bien d'accord et des ruptures de crédit
fournisseurs et rupture de crédit pour
les investissements également
et sans vous parler bien évidemment de
l'obligation légale qu'il aurait faite
de déposer les comptes avec les
conséquences derrière en matière
judiciaire puisque c'est une obligation
légale donc voilà mais moi ce qui me
préoccupe et ce qui me préoccupe la
profession aujourd'hui c'est plutôt la
rupture des crédits fournisseurs si on
n'est pas en mesure de déposer les
comptes en tout cas s'il est greffes ne
sont pas en mesure de les recevoir parce
que les déposer sur le guichet unique on
les dépose mais ça n'arrive pas aux
destinataires que sont les greffes donc
voilà là aujourd'hui c'est c'est notre
principale préoccupation en ce qui
concerne le guichet unique sachant que
les cessations
les modifications on a toujours des
difficultés c'est c'est un vrai frein à
l'activité économique aujourd'hui cette
histoire du geshi unique donc
ça va être très très compliqué
madame la Présidente pendant que vous
vous évoquiez ça
comme on est intervenu déjà plusieurs
reprises sur ce sujet là je pense que
étant donné l'échéance que nous
indiquait au 30 juin alors qu'auparavant
ça devait être réglé fin mars
je pense que si vous en êtes d'accord on
va faire un courrier à Bruno Le Maire et
un à Olivier agrégoire et on se
permettra de se rapprocher de vous pour
bien sûr bien volontiers pour indiquer
que les échéances arrivent et des
conséquences pour essayer de booster
tout ça quoi et si on n'a pas de réponse
bah on fera une question
mais les questions orales j'y crois trop
parce que c'est
bon voilà c'était simplement sur ce
sujet qu'on rebondisse sur l'humour
c'est-à-dire 95%
ne se fait pas c'est à vous déposer vous
dites vous déposez sur des chemises et
après c'est la transmission qui ne se
fait pas vers les rêves a priori alors
je sais pas si c'est la transmission qui
ne se fait pas parce que je suis pas
dans le coeur du système mais ce que je
sais c'est qu'à la réception ce qui
reçoivent alors d'après les greffiers
que j'ai rencontrés aussi pour évoquer
ce sujet d'après les greffiers ce qui
reçoivent n'est pas conforme avec ce
qu'ils attendent donc voilà et en
matière de dépôt et je vous parle pas
non plus de la complexité du guichet
unique par rapport à ce qu'on avait
auparavant c'est à dire que on on défile
des pages et des pages et des pages pour
mettre trois informations on passe un
temps fou sur ce nouveau guichet qui
excusez moi mais n'a pas été développée
avec je pense un comité utilisateur on a
même pas été nous expert-comp on est les
principaux utilisateurs et on n'a pas
été convié dès le départ aux commissions
au comité utilisateurs je sais même pas
je pense qu'il y avait même pas un
comité utilisateur au départ enfin
Eric était là il y avait même pas de
comité utilisateurs de Linky qui ont
développé donc voilà donc ça va être une
vraie problématique qui va moi je suis
rentrée en fonction vous l'avez dit fin
décembre
le 2 janvier j'étais c'est le sujet que
je maîtrise le plus le 2 janvier c'était
mon premier sujet guichet unique à 10h
du matin le 2 janvier il y avait plus
rien qui fonctionnait donc voilà
[Rires]
au niveau des défaillances vous m'avez
interpellé poser une question sur les
défaillances en 2023 est-ce qu'elles
vont augmenter comme je vous l'ai dit
dans mon propos il y aura une
augmentation alors après
on est au mois de début mai 2023 je suis
pas j'ai pas j'aimerais avoir des des
dons pour deviner ce qui va se passer et
ça me rendrait bien service mais de nous
ce qu'on voit aujourd'hui on n'a pas une
augmentation des défaillances de façon
importante on a une augmentation des
défaillances début 2023 par rapport aux
années précédentes et notamment on se
référence plutôt sur les années 2019
puisqu'on sait que 2020 2021 ce sont pas
des années significatives puisque le
quoiqu'il en coûte
a permis de de maintenir l'activité
économique et donc du coup il y avait
quasiment plus de défaillances mais là
pour l'instant on n'a pas de défaillance
de façon un nombre de défaillances de
façon très importante au jour
d'aujourd'hui donc voilà pour ce qui est
des liquidations amiable puisque c'est
ce que vous me disiez les commerçants
aujourd'hui préfèrent fermer avant de se
retrouver en liquidation judiciaire et
faire une liquidation amiable de façon
volontaire
j'avoue je sais pas on n'a pas de
chiffres là dessus je vous avoue j'ai
pas de chiffres là dessus par contre ce
qu'on constate et vous vous avez dû le
constater aussi c'est que dans certains
secteurs d'activités les changements de
mode de consommation de de nos
concitoyens ont eu un impact très
important je parle pour ça de tout ce
qui est commerce d'habillement
dans les centres-villes dans les
galeries commerciales on constate
aujourd'hui que le changement de mode de
consommation qui a été accéléré avec la
crise covid les confinements et les
fermetures globalement les Français
aujourd'hui ce qu'on peut constater
c'est que les les achats en la matière
sur internet alors je parle de
l'habillement parce que c'est un des
secteurs les plus impactés par ça mais
il y a d'autres secteurs d'activité qui
sont impactés on constate qu'il y a
vraiment là sur les changements de
consommation
des changements effectivement il peut y
avoir un petit risque à ce niveau là au
niveau de de
des mois qui vont venir
PGE
report plus long alors les reports de
PGV enfin voilà il y en aura pas plus
que ce qu'il y a eu par contre il existe
des procédures amiable
auprès des tribunaux de commerce en
termes de conciliation qui permet ou des
mandats il y a des procédures qui
existent auprès des tribunaux de
commerce dont les chefs d'entreprise
peuvent se rapprocher de leur tribunal
de commerce pour mettre en place ce sont
des procédures qui sont qui sont pas
publiques qui sont pas publiés il y a
pas comme les procédures collectives une
mention sur le cabiste disant que on est
en procédure collective que ce soit
le redressement judiciaire
ou
la liquidation judiciaire mais il existe
la conciliation le mandat Haddock et les
chefs d'entreprise peuvent se rapprocher
pour qu'il y ait une discussion entre le
l'entreprise
et le banquier qui a octroyé le PGE et
on a aussi la médiation
qui peut aussi intervenir donc il y a
des procédures qui existent qui sont oui
mais elles sont pas elles sont
effectivement elles sont pas assez
utilisées par les tpeme et effectivement
faudrait peut-être qu'on en fasse un peu
plus la promotion je suis d'accord aussi
avec enfin on connaît les conséquences
aussi en termes de notation bancaire des
entreprises qui font appel à ça je sais
j'en ai discuté lors de mon entrevue
avec Bruno Le Maire avec un de ses
conseillers en lui disant attention ils
peuvent effectivement y aller mais ils
ont peur par rapport à leur notation
enfin leur cotation Banque de France et
je veux dire par leur dans leur rapport
avec leur banquier effectivement il peut
y avoir un problème là-dessus mais
globalement je pense que ces procédures
ne sont pas assez utilisées par les
chefs d'entreprise notamment pour les
étalement un peu plus longs de PGE
alors la facture électronique et la part
de créativité des entreprises des
entrepreneurs
la facture électronique de toute façon
la facture électronique c'est un fichier
la facture en elle-même elle est normée
une facture elle est normée on a des
mentions obligatoires à mettre donc la
part de créativité aujourd'hui dans les
factures elle existe quasiment plus
parce qu'on a des textes qui encadrent
le mode d'établissement des factures qui
font que de toute façon on a des
mentions obligatoires un prix une
quantité
un prix unitaire etc hors taxes TVA on
n'a pas le choix donc la facture
électronique ne va reprendre que les
mentions qui sont déjà sur les factures
et qui sont déjà obligatoires sur les
factures
ou alors j'ai pas compris votre question
électronique ça se résume si vous voulez
parce que j'entendais dire vous allez
faire un comparatif d'un boulanger à un
autre sur le prix de l'énergie etc et
ma question c'est donc on met tout le
monde dans le même cadre et puis dès
qu'on a quelqu'un qui
qui cherche un peu moins de revenus qui
cherche un peu plus de créativité de
recherche ou je ne sais quoi enfin qui a
la passion de son métier qui est moins
là avec l'objectif du revenu est-ce que
lui il va pas avoir un une alerte rouge
à part d'administration fiscale etc
est-ce que est-ce que est-ce que ces
entreprises parce que aujourd'hui vous
voyez bien le système on va de plus en
plus faire de la normalisation faire de
la normalisation et cette normalisation
moi je trouve dramatique en termes de
créativité et je trouve que je trouve
que il faudrait quand même que votre
profession mettre un frein sur tout ça
parce que on peut pas tout le temps
aller dans dans ce nivellement par le
bas enfin c'est ça qui me fait peur
c'était surtout dans
comme source mais si on parle de la
farine il peut y avoir des écarts parce
que c'est un choix c'est de prendre tel
type de farine plutôt que l'autre pour
faire et là là c'est difficile de
laisser des fonctionnaires juge de
l'écart et ça le sujet après c'est
comparatifs dont Hervé a parlé en
matière d'accompagnement pour aider le
chef d'entreprise à savoir se situer
je suis expert-comptable j'ai un cabinet
j'ai des clients et quand je les
rencontre au moment du bilan enfin au
moment des rendez-vous ce qu'on appelle
des rendez-vous bilans pour expliquer
comment ça s'est passé leur année
comment ça va se passer enfin etc faire
de la essayer de faire un peu de
prospective avec des chefs d'entreprise
pour les accompagner au mieux
souvent il nous pose la question mais
comment je suis par rapport aux autres
ça il nous la pose la question alors
après chacun est et on va dire libre de
de d'avoir de la créativité dans son
métier etc mais c'est pas la facture
électronique qui va apporter plus de
normalisation ça existe déjà il y a des
nomenclatures professionnelles qui
existent et c'est nomenclature
professionnelle la première organisme
qui les fait et qu'il est qu'il est créé
c'est l'administration fiscale parce que
l'administration fiscale elle reçoit
toutes les données des entreprises et
elle est capable de de générer ces
moments de nature je veux dire quand
l'administration fiscale constate
comment comment
se déclenche certaines fois les
contrôles fiscaux c'est parce que
l'administration fiscale a constaté une
anomalie dans un indicateur par rapport
à la profession
donc ça existe déjà c'est pas la facture
électronique qui va le augmenter et en
même temps le fait de dire c'est de
l'accompagnement pour le chef
d'entreprise c'est à dire qu'on va pas
lui dire enfin à mon sens mais Hervé
pourra compléter mes propos c'est pas le
but c'est pas de lui dire vous consommez
trop d'électricité il faut changer votre
four ou etc c'est de dire voilà vous
avez une consommation d'électricité un
peu au dessus ou très au dessus de la
moyenne ou en dessous de la moyenne et à
lui d'analyser pourquoi si il a raison
et que il fabrique du pain de façon à ce
qu'il est obligé d'utiliser plus ces
outils qui sont les fours le pétrin etc
c'est lui qui le sait mais c'est pas une
obligation
mais ça existe déjà
ces données
je sais pas si présidente me permet de
peut-être de deux éléments effectivement
sur cette facture électronique il y a
l'aspect formel des choses il y a ce que
l'administration pourra en faire mais
c'est malgré tout et là je vous rejoins
un terreau d'innovation
un autre sens sur plusieurs points le
premier c'est effectivement
on peut atteindre un niveau de
granularité en termes d'information
effectivement quand on compare le
boulanger même on peut aller jusqu'à la
farine parce que dans la facture
électronique on a on a tout tout
l'information sous-jacente qui est
derrière ce qu'on voit ce qui est
visible et le non visible qui sera lu
par les machines et les logiciels peut
nous permettre de d'aller à un niveau
très très fin en termes d'information
pour pour outiller l'entreprise et donc
je pense que le l'innovation peut être
d'abord sur le d'une certaine façon en
gain de temps pour l'entreprise parce
plus on aura
ces process électroniques et plus on
aura des outils performants pour les
pour les pour les les
raffinés les travailler plus on pourra
dégager du temps pour que l'entrepreneur
le dirigeant puisse se concentrer sur
les missions sont sur son activité avec
plus de valeur ajoutée c'est aussi un
territoire d'innovation pour nous
expert-comptable des points comment on
le prend en terme de gain de temps mais
c'est surtout en faisant la combinaison
entre la donnée disponible financière
non financière et toutes les tous les
éléments qu'il y a derrière une facture
électronique peut nous permettre de
d'avoir des en croisant avec les outils
d'analyse les outils ou qu'on parle dont
on parle souvent d'intelligence
artificielle ou autre on peut aller très
loin dans ce qu'on peut produire en
termes de d'informations en termes de de
prédictibilité de certaines de certaines
situations quand je prends on prend la
météo par exemple qu'on croise avec ce
qui se passe en termes de chiffre
d'affaires la saisonnalité il y a plein
de choses qu'on peut dégager en termes
d'informations utiles pour le pour le
clan si si tu en es d'accord Président
je pense que c'est ça peut être des
sujets qu'on peut poser à condition de
de les travailler et c'est aussi le rôle
qu'on aura en tant qu'expert comptable
je me permets
j'en reviens à ce que vous venez de dire
cette discussion oui on demande toujours
enfin moi je vois dans mon domaine on va
demander nos collègues ce qu'ils font en
termes de comptabilité ou sans son etc
cette discussion là moi je veux l'avoir
avec mon expert-comptable mais en aucun
cas avec l'administration fiscale et je
veux surtout pas que l'administration
fiscale demain me dise mais attendez
vous n'êtes pas bon là sur sur votre
consommation d'énergie de farine il va
falloir que vous changer votre process
et ça mène à ma deuxième question
et il y a un moment il va falloir qu'on
mette en frein parce que j'entends
j'entends la météo etc etc mais on va
tomber fou avec toutes ces données
parce que
même pour tout le monde
mais et puis j'essaie de me dire si on
veut en arrière est-ce que on aurait mis
ce système là en place déjà 30 ans en
arrière est-ce que vous en serez plus
performant et est-ce qu'on la France
serait encore plus forte que ce scanner
j'en suis pas sûr
après je suis pas persuadé que la
facture électronique soit mise en place
pour apporter de la donnée de
comparaison pour le chef d'entreprise
etc etc on sait tous très bien à quoi va
servir la facture électronique à lutter
contre la fraude fiscale et la
principale qui est la TVA n'oublions pas
que la TVA est quand même la première
recette du budget de l'État donc voilà
bon
dans tous les pays où ça a été mis en
place et en même temps
c'est un peu le sens de l'histoire aussi
on pourra pas lutter contre la contre la
mise en place de la facture électronique
elle va être mise en place parce que
c'est le sens de l'histoire à nous
maintenant de se saisir de cette
obligation pour en faire un avantage et
pour en faire un avantage pour les
entreprises on sait que c'est
l'administration fiscale qui va s'en
servir à nous d'en tirer le meilleur
parti à nous experts comptables de
démontrer à nos clients que cette
obligation peut être une ressource pour
eux en matière de données
c'est ça quand on a une obligation enfin
alors peut-être c'est mon côté un peu
optimiste et naïf j'essaye de trouver
l'opportunité que je peux dégager de
cette obligation puisque sur cette
obligation là je n'ai aucun pouvoir je
vais alors plutôt que de la subir
essayons d'en tirer le meilleur parti et
pour les entreprises et pour les TPE PME
parce que c'est c'est eux qui vont en
subir je veux dire les les plus fortes
contraintes si on ne les aide pas et si
on ne leur démontre pas ce qu'ils
peuvent en tirer et en termes de données
je pense que c'est important
tant pis pour la créativité je dirais
mais on restera créatif je vous promets
on restera créatif on peut être créatif
à la donner
mais j'aimerais bien mon papa monsieur
le sénateur
[Rires]
[Musique]
je veux bien ici oui je veux bien
essayer mais je suis pas sûr d'être
écouté
ça va être une simplification
s'il vous plaît
le petit scoring qu'on m'avait évoqué
concernant les TPE sur on va dire un
certain nombre de je crois que c'était
une dizaine d'indicateurs qui étaient
prévus en termes de RSE voilà si vous
pouvez me répondre là-dessus est-ce
qu'il est vraiment établi est-ce qu'on
pourrait non on l'a alors effectivement
c'était une proposition
qui a été faite je crois l'année
dernière de mettre une dizaine
d'indicateurs et de le mettre dans la
liasse fiscale et après mûre réflexion
ça enfin sur la TPE PME ça me paraît
être une contrainte trop importante
aujourd'hui
on est
la tpeme n'est pas dans l'obligation
aujourd'hui
de fournir ces données mais par
capitalité ça va vite arriver sur la TPE
PME donc le
il m'avait semblé plus opportun toujours
pour rester dans la saisir l'opportunité
d'une contrainte de commencer à à un peu
habituer les TPE PME à fournir des
données extra financières mais des
données extra-financières qui puissent
être facilement capter
par l'expert-comptable puisque c'est
quand même c'est quand même des données
qui vont impacter et c'est
l'expert-comptable qui va être à la
manœuvre pour ça et quand
l'expert-comptable est à la manœuvre en
principe on a une petite facturation
derrière et donc c'est quand même un peu
désagréable pour les entreprises et
impactant pour l'entreprise donc si on
arrive à publier des données
extra-financières pour démarrer qui soit
facilement appréhendable donc on avait
pensé plutôt à des données en termes de
consommation d'énergie puisque on était
dans la crise énergétique enfin on est
toujours dans la crise énergétique et
que ça paraît important que le chef
d'entreprise prenne conscience de sa
dépense énergétique et en termes aussi
de d'égalité homme-femme dans les
entreprises voilà c'était les deux
données là sur lesquelles on est en
train de travailler et pas de les mettre
dans la liasse fiscale parce que
on va pas se recréer une obligation
fiscale
puisqu'on parle de simplification des
normes donc autant
enfin voilà on avait pensé le maître
plutôt dans le dans l'annexe des contes
annuels tout simplement mais voilà mais
les 10 on
estimé aujourd'hui ça viendra mais
aujourd'hui c'est peut-être pas le
moment de le faire
la présidente monsieur vice-président
malheureusement on est obligé de
conclure puisqu'on s'était fixé 10
heures chacun
un derrière d'autres obligations merci
à tous les deux de vos explications qui
recoupent totalement nous interrogations
il y en a il y en a 10 fois plus
évidemment
on pourra revenir peut-être sur des
thèmes précis à l'occasion en tout cas
j'aurais été à mon propos sur
le fait d'alerter
sur ce sujet et on aura besoin de votre
société quand vous voulez
je suis complètement d'accord parce que
plus on est nombreux plus ça peut
peut-être faire bouger un peu les choses
donc voilà si vous voulez je peux vous
laisser enfin on peut vous adresser la
copie de de de
mon petit discours d'introduction comme
ça ça permettra voilà
merci beaucoup
je voulais on vous les adresserez si
vous si vous le souhaitez pour que vous
l'ayez très bien merci beaucoup merci à
vous merci